[MUSIC]
Welcome, my name is Wil.
I'm one of the admission officers here
at Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Over the course of today's event,
we are going to be talking a little bit.
Not just about the experience itself, and
hearing from the folks
who just went through it.
But one of the questions I often get is,
hey,
what is that return on
investment look like?
And so, recognizing that return on
investment is going to look very different
for different people.
It's also going to look different
based on the life stage and
that career stage that you might be at.
And so,
the next few weeks many of our events
are geared towards helping us identify.
And define and articulate some of
the different ways that GSB experience
can help you both immediately out
of the business school experience.
Through your career five
years as a seasoned leader.
And what that look like for
you in that long term?
That long term story of
your personal narrative.
So, today we'll be focusing a lot on
that immediate after the few years after
you graduate.
So we'll meet our panelists.
I have a few warm up questions and
then we'll turn slowly to that Q&A box.
And really try to answer as
many questions as we can.
We'll have about 55 minutes together.
And so, let's go ahead and
meet our panelists.
Actually just a quick
[LAUGH] have backdrop.
Over 30,000 alumni around the world
organize into 60 alumni chapters.
So really great ways for you if you're
exploring different pieces of the world if
you're thinking about
different interest areas.
Ways to stay connected and
continue to make use of the GSB resources.
Even in the beyond, women's chapters,
diversity chapters.
You can even stay in contact
with our Career Services,
our CMC that Career Management Center.
They continue to provide services and
programs for alumni.
And we love the involvement think of that
one year, five year, ten year reunion.
Always amazing times on campus.
So, now let's get to our panelists.
If we can go left to right, so
Shawn, maybe starting with you.
If you could tell us
a little bit about yourself.
And let's just knock it out of the park.
Now what was your favorite course?
Or what was the most valuable course
that you took while at the GSB?
>> Yeah, sure, of course.
But thanks, Will.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Shawn Devon class of 2019.
So I graduated a few years ago.
I come from a fairly traditional
business background.
And I did two years of
investment banking and
a couple years of private equity
before going to Stanford.
And then I actually returned to the
private equity firm after Business School.
And do tech investing where I've
done there for several years.
My favorite course at Stanford was
a class called leadership perspectives.
Which is really interesting course
where you'd meet twice a week.
And the first session of each week would
basically be a high powered CEO or
senior person and
investment firm or entrepreneur.
And it would basically
be an unscripted and
unfiltered sort of Q&A between
the class and that person.
And it would kind of go into a bunch
of different areas, religion,
work life balance, marriage, career paths,
how to juggle two different
career opportunities.
And I thought that part was
fascinating because you get to hear it
straight from them.
And particularly around
work life balance or
what it means to have a two career,
marriage, or family.
And then the second session of that week
would basically be you meet with the same
four or five classmates.
And you discuss, what did you hear
in that session with that leader.
And how do you feel about it,
do you agree?
Do you disagree?
And so there's a lot of comparing and
contrasting between week to week.
And you really get to know those four or
five classmates very well.
I think,
we're sort of in the same boat as you.
And that they're interested in what
it means to do some of these things.
And think about these things thoughtfully.
But also they have different perspectives.
So, I thought was great class.
>> Shawn, was there a particular topic?
Or without necessarily going into
the speaker if the content was sensitive.
But was there a particular thing
that y'all kind of debated?
Or was an aha moment a learning
moment that you found really
powerful from that course?
>> Yeah, so
one interesting in that maybe 60 or
75% of the speakers were divorced or
had been divorced.
And a lot of them talked about work life
balance just could not work for them.
And they went through all the reasons why.
And so, we discussed this classmates.
And as peers how much does
work life balance mean to you?
And what does that mean?
And it was one of the speakers one
of the few who had been married for
20 plus years.
The way he described it and
we all resonated with us and
we all agreed with was,
hear all these things.
Is basically a list of questions that,
he wish he knew the answer to or
had spoken to with his partner
before they'd gotten married.
How much is too much traveling.
If one career is taking off and
the other person takes that back.
Getting these very specific and
explicit, yes, kind of question and
get answers with a partner.
It felt like a really interesting
exercise that at least me and
my three of my five classmates in my group
we had not done explicitly with our kind
of long term partner.
So, it was a little thought exercise like
that primarily centered around work life
balance I thought were fascinating.
>> Yeah,
we often talk a lot about the career and
here's where you're going to go next.
But thinking about those life
adjacent things that often inform.
Kind of how you approach life after.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, Sang welcome.
If you could tell us
a little bit about yourself.
And what was a memorable or valuable
class that you took while at the GSB.
>> Sure, so my name is Sang.
I graduated in this past year with Khalil.
And not this past year 2020 with Khalil.
And before GSB, I had worked in both
tech as well as Venture Capital.
And during the GSB made a career switch
to work in Investment Management.
Which more basically means I research
different companies that have stocks.
And decide whether or
not we should be investing in them.
And so,
when I think about my favorite class,
the one that really stands
out to me is actually
a class that I took about how to
incorporate different religious beliefs.
And spiritual beliefs into your leadership
style, and into your work professionally.
And this class was taught by the former
dean of religious life at Old Stanford.
And every week we'd kind
of sit in a circle.
And the first part of the class,
similar to what Shawn said,
there would be a prominent business
leader like the CEO of LinkedIn.
Or the CEO of all these different
companies either followed,
or practice a particular
type of spiritual belief.
And that person would come in talk
about how their experience influenced
their leadership style,
influence how they ran their company.
And how they set culture and
made decisions.
And then afterwards we would have
this no very active debate about what
constitutes privacy or boundaries or
what constitutes leadership and culture.
And that was a class that had a really
profound impact on me personally.
Because Shawn said, these are things
that you think you know until a question
gets posed by one of your classmates and
you realize you don't know.
I don't how you would have handled
the situation or how you would answer it.
So that class really
made a big impact on me.
Is there and this is out of your
curiosity from my friend and
it might be have been in your
rear view mirror to some degree.
But was there a question in particular
that you found really striking that you
might remember?
>> Yeah, I think every class
inevitably kind of meander to
the question of what is
the responsibility of a business leader?
Is it to maximize profits,
is it to build an enduring company
with a very strong culture?
Is it to take care of your employees,
is it to put your customers first?
And you can easily see how depending on
what kind of business you're in those
questions can become very
complicated very quickly.
And so I think that's probably what I
constantly left, I walked out of every
class kind of grappling with
that kind of decision of like.
What really is my responsibility
as a leader to my colleagues,
to my manager,
to my customers to everyone else?
>> Nice, thank you, Khalil you tell
us a little bit about yourself and
of course that really stuck out to you.
>> Yeah for sure, so as I mentioned,
I graduated in 2020.
Prior to the GSB,
I went to Amherst for undergrad and
spent my pre GSB career in marketing
research and strategy role.
So mainly on the agency side, then worked
in branded innovation consulting, as well.
I'm helping focus on how we think
about positioning brands, and
then have we launched mainly
physical CPG products into market.
Went to GCB, now we're at Facebook I'm
a product marketing manager.
Which basically means it's a mix of
marketing, business strategy and
product strategy of helping determine
what types of products we should build.
And then on the outbound marketing
piece of like, how do we talk and
position those products to customers.
My favorite class at the GSB that's
tough I'll say I'm going to say
to actually you're on the front and
soft skills with some cheating.
Some soft skills, I would say touchy feely
I think everyone will tell you that that's
an incredible class.
But I think for a lot of reasons that
class kind of changed both how I interact
in business settings, but also with a lot
of my personal relationships as well.
And that's a class that you sit in
a circle with 13 other people and
you talk about your feelings for
hours like many hours added time.
And then on the opposite end, I would say
the industrialist dilemma
taught by Rob Segal.
You meet with a lot of C suite executives,
so met with the CEO of GSK, CEO of Target.
And really got to really understand how
they think about their business as well.
>> And how do you think about
the industrialist dilemma like?
How would you encapsulate
that in like a few words,
not that it that would be easy at all but,
>> Yeah,
I think it the class just
really talks about all of egos
different problems that
a business can face.
So for example, with target we talked
about, okay, Amazon's entering the market.
How do you grow your business when there's
disruption happening all around you?
And then we brainstorm Ideas of how we
would do it often were completely wrong.
And then the CEO would come and
talk about how they thought about it.
So I think it's really different for
each business,
it's really about how did your
business adaptive stay agile.
When there are a bunch of different
pressures coming from like investors.
Or your internal employees,
consumers to ultimately make
the best decision for your business.
>> All right, Brian, class of 21.
Can you tell us a little bit
about yourself in this like short
window looking back, favorite class.
>> Yeah, it feels a little bit surreal
to be on an alumni panel because
it was literally weeks ago that I was
a student, so that's fun for me, I guess.
But yeah, my name is Brian,
I literally just graduated in June and
now working on a startup
venture based in San Francisco.
Yeah favorite class I
will follow Khaiil and
say that interpersonal dynamics also
the touchy feely is a terrific course.
And then I'll also add startup garage,
which was a great, great class for
me is one of the classes that my partner
and I use to launch our business.
So I have to have positive feelings about
startup garage as well, but basically,
if you if you're not familiar with it,
it's an experiential class.
So you're working on
a specific venture idea and
then you have advisors around you.
And throughout a structured program,
you're testing the resonance of your idea
with potential customers, and you're
building prototypes of your business.
So, it's kind of a fun hands on
way to test entrepreneurship
before graduating school.
>> Brian, can you tell us a little
bit more about startup garage?
There's a lot of questions that
I frequently get about it,
like what kinds of mentorship happened,
do folks actually get funded out of it?
How do you find a partner going into it
like or a group like can you give a little
bit of flavor about any of those
questions I just kind of threw at you?
>> Yeah sure, so
I'll start with forming a group that's
a big thing that happens on at school.
I don't think there's one
way to form a group people,
they have someone they
knew in a prior life.
And you're allowed to have other people
on your team as long as you have
Stanford people on your team.
It could be classmates in the MBA program,
It could be Stanford people and
other graduate schools that
aren't business programs.
So people have all sorts of ways
that they match up on teams, for
me I matched up with someone else in
the business school in the MBA program.
So we work together as a pair and
then in terms of how the program works.
So it's a two quarter program, and
you have a dedicated advisor each time and
this is someone you week,
my computer is reacting.
This is someone you work
with on a weekly basis and
then you also have other supporting
advisors that you work with.
In total, I think there's more
than like 10 faculty people who
are part of the sort of garage program.
And then lastly on funding, people do
get funded I don't know the statistics.
But my partner and I were funded and
I think many other people
in our class were funded.
So it is a path if you want it to
be to full time entrepreneurship.
>> Thank you Brian and
also welcome to alumni grade,
I think there are two journeys
that I hear a lot about.
So Shawn we'll be starting
with you on you came from PE,
you went back how do you think
about the value of the MBA?
And Like why do an MBA if you're
thinking about returning and then for
folks who might have pivoted.
Or did a little exploration, I'll be
coming to that side of the equation next,
so maybe Shawn can get us
kicked us off from Sonia For
those going back to the same job,
industry, employer, what was the biggest
takeaway from Stanford GSB
since it wasn't a career pivot?
>> Yeah, that's a great question and
actually when I was at Michigan undergrad,
I was actually in the undergraduate
business school there too.
So [LAUGH] folks will really
ask me why am I going back and
getting an MBA, and the way I thought
about it was sort of twofold.
So going to business school versus not.
And then, why Stanford Business School
versus any other business school?
So on the first part of that question,
I think the biggest thing for
me was network,
not only within the folks in your class.
But also the full alumni network
that you get access to and
really becomes incredibly
supportive from day one,
that kind of GSB offers,
I think that's probably number one.
Number two was for my peers who were also
in private equity or going back into
the industry or the sector that I
also worked in and was going back to.
You kind of see how their
firms looked at the world and
thought about investments and
you pick their brain, they pick yours, and
it's kind of a good learning
experience from that perspective.
And that you can see the landscape
a little bit better than when you're just
within your own firm or
your own group in private equity.
And then the third thing, which kind of,
to the good segue into Stamford
versus other business schools,
is the curriculum outside of what I
would call the core business classes.
So I wasn't going to Standford or
getting an MBA to learn accounting or
take a marketing course.
It was more about the soft skills and I
think that's where Stanford really shines.
I think a lot of folks go
to business school and
they want to learn how to become a CEO.
I was more interested in,
what do you need to do and
what do you need to learn
to become a leader?
And I think that's where
Stanford really shines.
And we've walked through some
of those classes already and
I'm happy to highlight a few more.
And then the last thing for me
specifically is I invest specifically in
technology and Stanford being
right in Palo Alto and so close to
San Francisco and San Jose, you're kind
of in the epicenter of technology.
So the way that, I guess, reflects
itself is one, a lot of speakers who
are in the area, this is pre-COVID,
would come to the classroom.
And you can build those relationships
just within those 45-minute sessions or
however long, after class and follow ups.
And the second is there's
a bunch of career tracks and
kind of club tracks where you'll
just go explore the area.
So, kind of being in this community was a
big pull for me for Stanford specifically.
So I hope that answered the question.
>> Yeah, it did, thank you.
And we'll actually come back to some
of those other leadership development
courses and lessons from there, because I
see a number of questions in the Q&A box.
So, hot topics, so
we'll definitely get there.
For our other panelists, whether it
was a small pivot or a larger pivot.
Can you talk about how Stanford
helped you along that journey,
even if it was just a little
bit of exploration?
Can anybody shed a little
bit of light there?
>> Sure, I can jump in.
So I actually was 99.9% sure
I was going to go back into
venture capital or at least a startup.
I'd been living in the Bay Area and
I loved the whole ecosystem.
And so when I got to Stanford,
I just wanted to experiment and
try different things.
And so it was one of these experiments
that actually led me to discover this
other area within financial services but
completely different type of work.
And it was kind of like one
coffee chat led to one interview,
led to one internship, and then before
I knew it, I'd kind of walked down this
other path and found something that
was much better suited for me.
So I would say,
even if you are 99.9% sure of something,
just opening yourself up to exploration
is really wonderful and gives you chances
to just learn things about yourself
even if you don't change career paths.
But I would say the other thing as well is
you just encounter so many perspectives.
You encounter people from so
many different backgrounds,
whether that's places they grew up,
industries that they worked with.
And so I would say, like Shawn alluded to
this, that even if you're going back into
a similar line of work or a similar job,
you will learn so much about the rest of
the world and other businesses that
will only make you more successful.
>> Cong, I have a question, you mentioned
from one conversation to an interview,
were these classmates, were these alumni,
who were some of these folks that kind
of serendipitously [LAUGH]
led you on this journey?
>> It was a path with many
different mentors but
I would say it started with classmates,
just hey, what did you do before school?
Why did you like that?
Why didn't you like that?
This company is coming to campus
because we have a lot of alums, and
they're going to come and
talk about their line of work.
Great, they have a formal internship
program, let's assign you a mentor.
What does it take to prepare for
these interviews?
And it kind of just,
every step of the way,
I don't think it's something I could
have done without the ecosystem.
And that ecosystem is more about
the people, present students and
alumni that kind of come
together to form that ecosystem.
>> Nice, thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> And then Brian,
there's a couple questions here,
and I might extend this
after your response.
Did you know you wanted to
go into entrepreneurship or
that you wanted to start a company,
how did that happen?
And then kind of at a broader level for
the other folks,
how solid of an idea did you have
coming into business school?
There's a question here from Caroline
about how helpful the GSB was at
helping you identify your passion or
the things you wanted to do.
Ans so, I think we might have
alluded to a little bit there but
maybe let's start with you, Brian.
Did you know you want it to go into this?
And then we can blow up the conversation.
>> Yeah, kind of,
I started business school and
the goal in my heart
was to start a company.
One of the first classes I had in
the fall quarter of my first year,
the teacher had us write down in class
what our dream goal essentially was.
And that was my goal, so early on, my goal
was to start a company, but it was also
something that I was very afraid of and
I didn't know if I had what it took.
I didn't have a specific idea,
I didn't have a partner, I mean,
there were a lot of things that I thought
I didn't have that would keep me from
achieving that goal, so
it felt very scary to me.
So, part of business school for
me was really through a lot of ways
building the confidence that
it's not such a scary thing.
And then you can de-risk and de-risk and
de-risk by making various decisions,
like who you partner with,
and what you work on, and
this is stuff you can start to do.
And that was really, I think,
a two-year process for me.
But I've reached the ultimate point
where a few months before graduation,
my partner and I were mentally
prepared to commit to each other and
to the rest of the people
we are working with,
that this is something that we are really
going to dedicate ourselves to.
And who knows if it works out but
we're going to give it everything we can.
And I think Stanford absolutely was a huge
part for me of building that confidence
and gaining some tools along the way
of how to go about starting a company.
>> Nice, and then Khalil,
as you were at the GSB,
did you have a clear thread of what you
want to do or was there exploration?
And how did you go about identifying
those things that were meaningful for
you in the career search?
Yeah, I think I knew things I enjoy
I mean broadly things that I enjoy,
so I knew I enjoyed marketing.
I was pretty sure I wanted
to be an operator and
play less of a consultant role.
But outside of that I wasn't really and
I knew I was interested in technology.
So that's like one of the main
reasons why I chose GSB is because I
knew I'd be surrounded in Silicon Valley.
But I think being at the GSB
really opened my eyes to all of
the different opportunities
that were out there.
And just with classmates, right,
even just on this call, there's so
many people with so
many different backgrounds.
So like I started off the GSB with just
talking to a lot of people about what they
did before business school and
trying to figure out if that
would be interesting to me.
Even venture capital,
I was like, that seems cool,
there's some marketing strategy there,
there's some business strategy there.
But talking to someone I was like,
I don't know if that's,
when I really dug into it,
it really helped me figure out that okay,
no that wasn't the perfect spot for
me at this moment.
So, I think it really just being immersed
by so many people as a lot of people on
this call mentioned,
was really, really valuable.
And yeah and
helped solidify that product marketing was
a role that I wanted to do post GSB.
>> Nice, I know there's a report
that comes out every year from our
Career Management Center
about the outcomes.
And in that report, they talk a little bit
about where these opportunities came from.
I think the split was a third
come from opportunities through
the Career Management Center,
a third come from students and alumni.
And another third come from, that might be
self source or if they were sponsored and
are returning to their company from there.
I'm curious, has anybody on this call
worked with the Career Management Center,
or were you representative of the other
two thirds of the outcomes here?
>> I definitely worked with
the Career Management Center.
>> Can you talk a little bit about how
they supported you through that or
some insight into there?
>> Yeah, so
I worked pretty heavily with Grace and
Gino who are just two of
the faculty in the Career Center.
They're both really great, they're both
kind of specialize in different things.
So, I spent a ton of time with Gino on
actual preparing for actual interviews.
So, we would go through,
I would set a time, we'd have 30 minutes
to just talk through the cases and then
I use Grace as my mentor of long-term,
what should I be doing in my life and
how should I be thinking about that?
They've both been super invaluable,
and yeah, so
they've actually both of them
have been instrumental in helping
me determine what role and what types
of companies I would want to work for.
>> Right, and Brian I saw you smiling and
nodding as [LAUGH] Khalil is talking
about some of the folks he worked with,
were you able to interact with
anybody from the CMC during your time?
>> Yeah, I was smiling because I
worked with Grace a lot too, and
I would totally recommend her.
She's fantastic.
Yeah, I worked with them
less on a full time job, but
part of my theory of testing
entrepreneurship was to see how I liked
working in a non-financial services role,
which is what I was previously doing.
And so, I used my summer,
between the first and
second year to do two internships that
were totally different from finance.
One was at a healthcare company
doing product work, and
one was at an ecommerce
company doing strategy work.
And those were just tests for me on how I
liked those types of different roles, and
Grace was invaluable towards thinking
about how I should pick those and
figuring out companies that
will be good fits within that.
So, they were very helpful for me.
>> Career Management Center,
awesome people,
I get to work on a floor with them.
It's amazing anytime I get
to interact with them and
talk about kind of how they
help support our community.
So, we're going to shift gears a little
bit, there's a question here from Nicole,
about, if after graduation, if you could
go back in time and start the program all
over again, what advice would you give
yourself as an incoming MBA candidate?
Usually I'll save a question like this for
the end, but
I have a different end question
of kind of to motivate us.
But as you think about yourself,
two, three years ago,
what advice would you give yourself
as an incoming MBA candidate?
And open anybody wants to start.
>> I can start, I actually got this
advice from several people but
it's kind of hard to contextualize
it until you're at campus.
But a lot really happens,
in your first quarter, just school,
social, sometimes even
the internship recruiting.
And I think the biggest thing
that I wish I knew was,
the ability to say no to things.
And kind of defensive calendaring,
and because I think folks will just fill
up your Google calendar with stuff and
you want to go to everything
truthfully because it's a lot of fun.
It can get a little overwhelming at times,
I consider myself like
a fairly outgoing person.
But when you meet everyone at Stanford,
everyone's dialed like 12 out of 10
particularly in the first quarter.
So it's fun but
it feels a little crazy and
that first quarter you're
really asking yourself,
well how did I get in here because
you're meeting so many amazing people.
That alone time actually I think really,
really helps.
My girlfriend at the time, now fiancé,
she lives in San Francisco and
one of my favorite parts truthfully of
the week was whenever we go visit her,
because it's an hour long
car ride to San Francisco.
And it was a one-time where you're not
kind of surrounded by people talking.
And I know a lot of folks got
that through, through exercise or
meditation or other ways, but
I would highly recommend it,
block off time for yourself because,
if you don't it no one else will.
>> I love the phrase defensive calendaring
I think I'm going to use that all
the time now.
Any your tips for how people might be
able to defensively calendar especially
knowing like the GSB environment?
>> Yeah, I would just block off like
30 minutes to an hour every day.
Whether it's a long stretch of class or
a bunch of back to back coffee chats
where you are kind of all quote unquote,
on with folks.
That's usually when I would do it
from the gym or read or podcast.
I think it's plugging that in.
And a lot of this settles too after the
first quarter, once everyone kind of gets
a little bit more comfortable with
the environment and themselves and their
classmates, but it's that first quarter
work, it can feel a little overwhelming.
>> So in addition to defensive
calendaring, what other advice might
one of the other panelists give
yourself as an incoming MBA candidate?
>> Yeah, I think a lot of what Shawn
says definitely resonates with me.
I, on that note of it being super busy,
you're going
to start day one and
it's going to be crazy busy with so
many different things and
activities you can focus on.
And I've never been busier in
my entire life, there was not,
there's, You don't have
time to do everything.
So you're going to have to prioritize.
And I think having a clear
mindset of before,
of what you want to get
out of the experience.
What you want to get out of each,
whether you want to do it each year,
each quarter,
however you want to look at it.
But like coming in with that and
making sure that how you split your time
represents what your priorities are, is,
in my perspective, incredibly important.
So, that'd be my advice.
It's like figure out exactly what
you want to get out there and
make sure that your time, your energy
is devoted in those categories.
Because it's like so easy to get wrapped
up in everything else that's going on.
Everything that's thrown at you
like social events, as I mentioned,
there's going to be so much in q1.
But then all of a sudden,
the first recruiting is going to be
consultant recruiting is going to like
up and then you're going to be like,
should I be a consultant.
And you're going to end, it's like you
didn't want to be a consultant before but
everything gets, it's so
easy to get wrapped up in mixer,
like really having a clear
vision of of what you want.
>> It's funny when everybody on the call
kind of laughs at something because
that feeling just kind of kicks
back in as you were talking about,
consulting recruiting starts,
do I want to be a consultant.
I just saw a lot of faces light up,
because fairly that thought
process very common.
Let's switch gears again, I did promise to
talk about the leadership curriculum and
that's one of the things that we
hear a lot about on our panel.
So, door says question at the top about
what area of your leadership potential
did you feel have the greatest
opportunity for development?
And how did GSB help fill those
gaps slash strengthen those areas?
So I'm going to broaden this question
a little bit because I think coming
into business school,
you might have thought about, hey,
here's an area that I
would like to develop.
But coming out of the experience,
sometimes there's areas that you didn't
realize, were opportunities for growth and
those were aha moments for you.
So we'll open it up.
So either areas that you knew you wanted
to develop and how did you kind of target
that or, hey, realization of I did
develop greatly in this area and how.
So either looking forward or looking back.
Maybe Brian because you have one of
the fresher [LAUGH] experiences.
Can you get us kicked off and
then Sang, we'll come to you next.
>> Yeah, so my answer,
when I started at Stanford when I applied,
I was not,
I was focused on entrepreneurship and
I think exploring
the world beyond finance.
But I wasn't focused on
the Arbuckle Leadership Program.
But that was something I
ended up focusing on so,
what that is it's a program that
you apply to in your first year.
And it's focused on communication
with other people and
how groups work together and
how teams work together.
And it's also I think, focused on knowing
yourself and there's classes that
are directed towards, you're just getting
a finer point on what you value and
why you value it and how you want to
manifest those things in your life.
And so as I started taking those classes,
I think I saw that I was
taking a lot out of it.
And that it was really a period
of a lot of personal growth for
me in terms of just really being,
for the first time of my life,
I think rigorous about what I
was searching for and why and
how far I was willing to go to get it.
And how I could really communicate better,
because I think I was actually fairly
closed off in my communication
before Business School.
So yeah, I think for me, reflecting
back on the experience it has to
be my communication,
was the biggest growth area.
And from that I think it's, part of it's
about knowing what you want and part of
it's about knowing how to say things and
how to communicate your needs and desires
to other people in a way that's also
respectful of their own needs and desires.
And there's whole classes
on that at Stanford, but
that ended up being by far my, I think,
most important takeaway from school.
>> You use this really fascinating
word rigorous, like the rigorous
kind of approach to some of this,
personal core skill development.
What were some of the structures that
you would say contributed to that rigor?
Like how would you kind
of put words to that.
>> Well, I think something like Coolio
was just saying is part of I think
was the Business School gets you
to do is to reflect all the time.
And so you go and you take some action,
and then you think about how did that go?
And how do I want it to go
differently in the future?
And I think Business School just really
ingrains that habit in you because, for
one, a lot of the teachers are advocating
that approach every week, every quarter.
Some say every day, you're writing
down what you want to happen,
why you want it to happen, what
are you going to do to make it happen?
It's like this huge exercise and
self reflection.
But you do it so
much that I think it starts to kind
of embed itself as a personal habit.
And I've seen a lot of benefits from that,
just being more intentional with
how I spend my time and therefore,
you see that you achieve more of the
things that you actually want to achieve.
And you don't spend time on
the stuff that you don't find as.
>> Awesome Sang.
How about yourself?
How did you think about
leadership potential coming in?
What did you want to develop?
Or looking back, what was an area that
you found yourself growing a lot in?
>> Yes, so I think the first
one that comes to mind for
me is before business school,
I was always in these kind of high stress
situations and I had effective but
not great coping mechanisms.
So I would, call a friend and
rant about work or
I would order a pizza or just I had
all these like systems about how,
I'm having a hard time at work this
is how I'm going to get through it.
And those things work when you're 22 or
24.
But one of the things I took away,
was this idea of peer coaching and
then ultimately self coaching.
And so there are classes that
are formally built around this, but
it's also just embedded in the DNA
of the entire student class.
Where in every class, formal or
informal you end up reaching out to
your very talented and smart and
wise classmates for their advice.
Asking them for how they would approach
a problem, what they would do.
And then ultimately,
through exercises like journaling,
like reflection, or there's even
classes where you send out a survey and
solicit feedback from people about
your own behaviors and your brand.
But you kind of develop this
way of self coaching and
I think that's something
that I really appreciate.
And now that I've been out of GSB for
a while, where now when I feel stressed,
I'm not like you know door
dashing a pizza all the time,
I may be just taking a step back and
thinking, okay, why are you stressed?
What's happening, is this,
what can you do or, go for a walk or
you kind of learn these processes for
handling things.
And I think that's something that sounds
silly but, it's really taking very
smart and hardworking people but showing
them how they can maybe be as smart and
as hardworking but in a healthier and
more sustainable way.
You've this idea of self
coaching I find so fascinating.
Do you have any insights or tips for folks
out there about maybe something that you
learned along the way that others might be
able to adapt into kind of there everyday?
>> Yeah, I think one thing is this
act of writing things down and
journaling to yourself.
We live in such a fast digital age that
taking pen to paper can seem really silly.
But [COUGH] kind of like Brian alluded to,
there is a lot of power in sitting down,
whether that's every day or
every quarter or whatever.
And writing your own thoughts out and
kind of seeing it on paper and
even just going through that.
And it's something that whenever
I can be consistent with it,
I do notice a lot of benefit.
And so I think just journaling
self-written reflections,
goal setting anything like that could be,
I think, it's very powerful.
>> All right, so we are getting close to
the end and I want to make sure we go to
a area that I find very near and dear to
my heart, [LAUGH] the application process.
And so for everyone out there
as awesome as our panelists are,
as awesome as our students and alumni are,
they have no idea why they were admitted.
And they probably will never know,
[LAUGH] why they were admitted.
For all things admissions related
if you're curious about the process
definitely check in with
the MBA admissions office or
check out our website.
There's a ton of great information there.
But that doesn't mean there
might have been some learnings,
talking about journaling and
self-reflection.
Some things kind of on this back end
that you might have wished that you did
a little bit more or
have might be able to share with people.
So maybe Shawn would start with you,
and I'm going to be selfish and
go around the circle he'll Shawn,
Coolio, Cong, and then Brian.
So maybe go in reverse
chronological order.
Thinking back to when you were
applying to business school,
any tips that you would give
a younger you to help make
that process as kind of
approachable as possible?
>> Good question.
It's interesting because my fiance
is actually she's in business school
at Stanford right now, and I, [INAUDIBLE]
>> Can you repeat that
please I think you broke out for
just a little bit.
>> Yeah, of course, sorry, so
my fiance is actually at Stanford
right now, getting her MBA.
She's class of 2022,
social starter, second year.
So I don't really remember my application
process, I certainly remember hers.
Because one of the more reasons who I was
more stressed out when you're kind of
watching someone you've apply versus
when you yourself are applying.
And I think what something she did that I
thought was really helpful was outside and
was just talking to students in my class.
She tried to reach out to a lot of alumni
that were relatively recently graduated,
just to get a sense of the place.
Because she'd been there obviously as
a significant other when I was a student,
but it's very different than
the student experience.
So she was, Hey,
sorry, I think my headphones died,
hopefully you can hear me?
It's probably as I need to wrap this up.
I think was most helpful was talk to as
many students as possible current and
otherwise recently graduated to just
get a sense of what the place and
the culture is.
Because I think reflection of that in your
essay is obviously important, but more so
understanding that it's the right fit for
you.
Because I'm always amazed by folks like
will and the rest of the admission class.
How they're able to stitch together
a group of folks who are so
different set up so
much in common at the same time.
So that's the thing that's critical is
understanding what Stanford's about,
what do you think you're
going to get out of it?
And what the places like?
And I think the easiest way to do that,
is through conversations with
people who've been there.
>> Yeah, and for
folks who might not know how to start,
definitely I would also recommend either
checking out some of our webinars.
because there are times when you just
aren't able to connect at that individual
level maybe it's time, resources, network.
The point of many of our summer series is
to provide an opportunity to learn more
about the student experience from
folks who just went through it.
We're also recording many of these and
posting them online.
So as you're thinking about some
of these topics through the year,
if you're thinking for the future you'll
have a repository of information that you
can always come back to.
And we're always here curious to
know what you're interested in and
that helps me created new events for
you as well so, thanks Shawn.
Carlile, what about yourself?
Tips for a younger you.
>> [LAUGH] I think the part
where I won't provide that
much insight into is the actual
like GMAT you got to crunch and
spin and that's was the worst part for me.
I don't know if anyone else on
this panel has good ways for
how to get through that, please share.
But for
me that was definitely the hardest part.
The second hardest part was, okay,
that's done, I got the score I want,
that's the way.
It's crafting your story and
I think that's incredibly
important as you're going to bind to,
say eight schools,
you have eight schools there,
they all have different essays.
But ultimately you're
telling the same story, and
you're branding yourself to tell that
same story across different environments.
So it's figuring out and spending the time
upfront to figure out what your story is.
And there's a lot of
self-reflection involved in
figuring out what matters most to you.
And then finding strings
that tie those passions,
to all of your different activities,
all your different careers
that I promise you it's there.
And then once you find it you can pull
on personal and professional experiences
to really tell that holistic story
to the school you're applying to.
>> Okay, thank you, Cong.
>> So I think my one advice would be,
I remember feeling so intimidated and
thinking that there's 10,000 people
that apply and only so many get in.
And so my advice be think about what you
would contribute to your class in addition
to just thinking about everything
Stanford has to offer.
Because the reality is once you get there,
you are part of the DNA.
And so you will be helping your classmates
and bringing your lived experiences.
And so I think that is something
I didn't do enough of, I was so
intimidated and just scared.
But really think about if you were
a student in this community and
at this place.
What are some of the things that only
you could bring to your classmates or
you could bring to the experience for
others?
And that I think is a great way to kind of
get your wheels moving both in terms of
figuring out your own
story like Khail said.
But also tying your lived experiences and
your dreams and
aspirations with Stanford and kind of
bringing those two things together.
>> Then, Brian taking us home.
>> Yeah, I think I'll just say one thing,
which is,
what I noticed at school
was shocking to me.
How many people in my class said
they almost didn't apply to
Stanford because they thought
that they wouldn't get in.
So I think my recommendation is,
if you think that the Stanford
program excites you,
please do yourself a favor and apply.
>> Thank you, and to that effect,
I encourage you if you haven't done so
already, continue this
journey at mystanford.mba.
You're able to do things like
create a personalized dashboard.
So, if you are in the process of applying,
there's an application tracker so
you'll be able to know where and
each step you are.
If you're thinking about
either this year or
the future we also launched application
week, just this past month.
And we've saved the recordings
again on our GSB YouTube channel,
including workshops on
how to start your story,
ways to communicate your
story in the written format.
As well as what are different ways of
thinking about how do you communicate it
verbally, whether that is
thinking about networking or
even a behavioral based interview?
How do you prepare for that?
How are you able to most effectively
communicate who you are?
What matters to you?
What you've done and how you've done it?
So, thank you again,
everyone for joining us today.
Thank you to our panelists.
Hopefully, we'll be able to interact
much more again in the future.
But until then, take care, stay safe and
have a wonderful rest of
the weekend everyone.
[MUSIC]